Абсолютно  всі жителі села Висока піч займаються цією справою.
Я вам відверто скажу:
я себе не вважаю таким-от видатним полуничником.
Якщо по п’ятибальній системі оцінювати, то я  десь такий собі трієчник.
Вадим Дацюк  мешкає у селі Висока Піч, що на Житомирщині.
Має свій город, на якому працює після роботи в місцевій школі вчителем математики.
І "трієчник по полуницях ", в розумінні вчителя, це коли з 15-ти соток за сезон
можна зібрати півтонни полуниці. Щоправда, для цього треба багато попрацювати.
Ось в мене  друзі мої  запитують, що мовляв, посидив би вдома.
Я кажу вже кілька років, що для мене це фітнес.
Якщо люди там десь в містах платять по  400- 500 гривень
за  абонемент, щоб піти та покрутити якісь там тренажер,
то я покручу педалі велосипеда. 2,5 км в дві сторони, попрацюю плоскорізом,
побуду на свіжому повітря та ще і маю за це якісь прибуток!
Вадим Дацюк в свої 59 років каже, що в селі Висока Піч він - чи не наймолодший полуничник.
Здебільшого цією "городньою справою" займаються люди 60+.
Причому настільки успішно, що ТЕтерівська ОТГ, куди село Висока Піч приєдналася півроку тому,
вирішила підтримати полуничників. Ба більше, спробувати розкрутити, так би мовити, цей "полуничний" бренд.
Селом крокує полуничний фестиваль з полуничними немовлятами в головній ролі.
Висока Піч заявляє про себе не просто як "полуничне село". А те, що вирощує екологічну полуницю.
Пробуємо безкоштовно! За пробу гроші не беремо!
Полуниці для всіх вистачить! Вирощую домашню –без хімії та ГМО.
Мета фестивалю, який вперше провели в 2019-тому, -
підтримати усі майже 200-ті сімей, які тут займаються  полуницями,
дати їм майданчик для продажу своїх ягід та для обміну досвідом вирощування.
Показати свої роботи, свій врожай і так саме сказати:  "Ось, я -полуничник! Я вирощую полуниці!"
А як Вас звуть?
Іван Леонидович.
Я сьогодні привіз 6 кг для усіх гостей.
Тетерівська ОТГ хоче цим фестивалем також  привернути увагу молоді до "полуничної справи".
Адже мотивації працювати на своїх городах  у молодих людей немає.
Вони їдуть по заробітки до великих міст або за кордон - збирати ту ж саму полуницю за інші гроші.
Пенсіонер Іван Коцюбинській з дружиною має 10 "полуничних" соток.
І, за його підрахунками, з однієї сотки в цьому сезоні вони заробили не більше 1000 гривень.
Над полуницею дуже важка праця.
Двічі в рік треба сполоти і вручну.
Люди -  старше покоління вирощують цю полуницю.
А я впевнений, що молодь на майбутнє …,
що полуниця буде, як Аркадій Райкін говорив, "іскопаємоє".
Вадим Дацюк розповідає, що ще кілька років тому він з дружиною – теж вчителькою, української мови,
обробляв ледь не в чотири рази більше грядок полуниці.
В лихі 90-ті, коли зарплатню ніде не платили, тут в селі був справжній полуничний бум.
Її вирощували ледь не всі майже 3000 жителів.
Таких "полуничних городів" навколо було багато. Зараз більша частина землі заросла бур’янами.
Вадим Дацюк каже, що займатися полуницею стає дедалі більше невигідно.
В Житомирі, скажімо, ціна за один кг - 45 гривень.
Ці оптовики, які сюди приїжджають, вони закуповують от цю  полуницю по 15,
а собі мають навар 2-3 рази.
Ось так. Тому, якщо хтось думає, що я або хтось інший, який займається полуницею
і виходить з цим  на ринки, ми тут ці гроші гребемо лопатою, то це далеко не так.
В Високій ПЕчі багато років існує майданчик біля траси,
куди селяни з усіх навколишніх селищ здають оптовикам свої ягоди.
Інколи, як розповідають DW городники, оптовики занижують ціни нижче собівартості самої полуниці.
Люди вимушені просто роздавати безкоштовно свої ягоди або ж навіть закопувати їх.
Люди переорюють, тому що немає збуту.
Я ще можу поїхати  в Житомир, чи навіть вийти на дорогу і на трасі продати,
а людина-пенсіонер , бабця, приміром,
вона виростила цих два відра. Ось, стоїть машина вінницька.
І от такі, як кулаки, люди несуть і по 10 гривень віддають. Просто віддають, щоб не згнило.
Полуничникам Тетерівської  ОТГ конче необхідний хоча б міні-консервний завод.
Людмила Кулинчук колись мала понад 20 "полуничних" соток
і не знала, куди діти ягоди, тож скоротила вирощування до двох соток.
Вона вважає, що ОТГ по силах створити і систему збуту.
Якщо ОТГ може організувати заготовку і постачати на завод…
В кожному селі поставити машину, де люди мають прийти та здати, от це було б правильно.
В Тетерівській ОТГ розуміють, що підтримувати треба не лише городників.
Треба сприяти загалом розвитку полуничного фермерства, якого тут немає.
Фермерів немає тільки через те, що  немає такого збуту для полуниці.
Якби в нас працював  би переробний цех,
то це було б набагато краще.
Вадим Дацюк в якості хобі за ймається краєзнавством. І в своїй школі зробив музей.
Одна з експозицій присвячена полуниці. Адже полуничній традиції села вже понад 70 років.
Тут її почали вирощувати в великих обсягах після Другої світової війни.
Хтось сюди просто завіз самий простенький сорт
в 50-тих роках, називався "коралки" і "паузунки".
Вони були маленькі, були схожі на суницю.
Вони якось прижились і далі пішло.
Це мапа відображає, як багато оптовиків їздили в Високу Піч в радянські часи.
Тут працювали полуничні радгоспи, великі переробні заводи, тут робили смачні вина з ягід.
Селяни тоді примудрялися вирощувати полуницю в своїх городах і возили на продаж по всьому СРСР.
Вадим Дацюк, як і багато селян, хоче відродити це полуничне мистецтво.
В Тетерівській громаді, яку створили в 2015-тому році, одразу почала розвивати в себе туристичні та фестивальні проєкти,
хочуть зробити з полуниці ще і туристичний бренд.
Я бачу в проведенні фестивалів залучення
людей  до творчості фестивальної, мистецької.
А так як це  фестиваль полуниці, то це
розвиток  фермерства і приватного  господарства.
А полуниця в поєднанні  з мистецтвом-це залучення туристів  до громади.
В Тетерівській ОТГ розуміють, що "полуничним" може бути не лише окреме село Висока Піч, а й уся громада.
Адже ґрунти тут ніби створені природою саме для цієї смачної ягоди.
План дій щодо залучення інвесторів задля налагодження системи збуту та переробки
ОТГ планує представити вже в цьому році.
Відкриття ринку землі також може стати поштовхом для розвитку ягідного фермерства.
І не лише полуничного. Адже тут вирощують багато і смородини, і чорниці.